In recent years, open access has steadily gained
momentum. Most journals and publishers today have
open access channels and authors have the choice
to publish open access. However, many authors,
particularly those who are relatively new
to academia, are still in a haze about open
access publishing. What is open access? What
is the rationale behind publishing open access?
What are the different venues for publishing open
access? Such questions bother authors and they are
often skeptical about publishing open access
as there are several myths about open access.
Open access is built upon the idea that
scientific research should be made freely
available to all so that others can build
upon it and help escalate scientific progress.
Traditionally, the academic publishing industry
has followed a subscription-based model.
This model requires readers to pay
for the content that they read.
Typically, libraries purchase bulk subscription
to a journal so that members or students can
access the journals. But as subscription
charges for journals started increasing,
libraries found it increasingly
difficult to purchase expensive journals.
This was particularly true for libraries and
institutions in developing countries where
funding was scarce. As a result, researchers often
could not access studies that they wished to,
and this started affecting the progress
of research. The need to remove this
roadblock gave rise to the open access model of
publishing in which readers have unrestricted
and immediate access to research after it has
been published with the permission to reuse it.
What are the different venues
for publishing open access?
Broadly speaking, there are two models for
open access publishing : gold and green .
Gold open access journals give readers free access
to peer reviewed articles, but the publication
charges are borne by the authors. Today, most big
publishers offer open access options, and some,
like plause, are purely open access. There are
several major directories of open access journals,
most notably Directory of Open Access Journals,
or DOAJ, which can help researchers identify
open access journals in their field. Under the
gold open access model, authors have different
kinds of journals to choose from :
Full open access journals . All
articles published in such journals are freely
available for readers on the journal website.
Some of these journals are subsidized,
and financed by an academic institution,
a learned society, or by the government; but
others may require the payment of a fee from the
authors, known as article processing charges,
once the paper is accepted for publication.
Hybrid journals . Most of the articles
in these journals are paywalled,
with only some content open. Authors can
choose to provide open access to their
articles by paying an extra fee. This fee
is generally known as open access fee.
Delayed open access journals . In this model,
articles become free for readers some time after
initial publication. The time period for which the
article is paywalled is known as embargo period.
For most journals, the embargo period is
six to twelve months. [sPause sec=1 ePause]
Green open access . Under green open access,
authors publish in subscription-based journals,
but at the same time deposit their
articles in an open access repository.
This is known as self-archiving. Thus,
although the journal is behind a paywall,
readers have free access to the article
through the repository. Authors who cannot
pay the fees for publishing in open access
journals often take this route. However,
articles may not be peer reviewed prior to posting
in a repository. Another point to be kept in mind
is that not all subscription-based journals allow
authors to post their paper on a repository.
Authors should, therefore, check the website
of their target journal to find out whether
self-archiving is allowed, and preferably take
the journal’s permission before self-archiving.
Open access repositories can be institutional or
independent, subject-specific, such as bioRxiv,
Nature Precedings, and PubMed Central,
or multidisciplinary such as arXiv.
There are three basic versions of an article
that can be self-archived in repositories :
Pre-Prints : This refers to the author’s copy of
the article before it has been peer reviewed .
Post-Prints : This also
refers to the author’s copy,
but after it has been peer reviewed, with the
suggested revisions incorporated, but before the
publisher has formatted it for publication .
and, Publisher’s version :: This refers
to the final PDF of the article that is
formatted and appears in print or online.
As mentioned at the outset, authors are
often unsure about publishing open access.
This is largely due to some popular
misconceptions about open access in their minds.
Let us try to dispel some of these myths :
Open access journals are not peer reviewed :
This is an absolutely wrong idea.
A journal’s peer review policy has
nothing to do with its access policy.
Most open access journals are peer-reviewed .
Open access journals have low impact factors :
This is, once again, a myth. Many open
access journals publish highly cited
articles and receive high impact factors .
Publishing in open access journals is expensive :
Authors often avoid publishing in open access
journals as they feel that they will not be able
to afford the high APCs. However, the truth is
that not all open access journals charge APCs,
and the ones that do generally have the
APCs clearly mentioned on their website.
APCs vary across journals and are not always high.
Additionally, many universities or funding bodies
bear the APCs. Also, open access journals often
waive fees for researchers in developing countries
and those researchers who are in financial
difficulty. For example, many Nature Publishing
Group journals have an APC waiver policy .
Open access publishing does not offer copyright
protection or credit to authors : In fact, for
many open access journals, such as PLOS or BMJ,
authors retain copyright after publication.
Additionally, most open access journals use
Creative Commons licenses under which authors
always receive credit when their work is reused.
In summary , As an early-career researcher,
it is extremely important for you to recognize
the importance of publishing open access.
Science can progress only when immediate,
unrestricted access to research is provided.
We hope that in the coming years, researchers show
more willingness to publish open access so that
the scientific community, policy makers, and the
general public can benefit from their research.